et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec marc naze shir ali sociologue
franco iranienne enseignante à sciences
po bonsoir marnaise shir ali merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
tout d'abord peut-on évaluer l'ampleur
de la pandémie en iran il est très
difficile de savoir ce qui se passe en
iran la situation iranienne est très
confuse dans le sens où l'état a décidé
de ne pas dévoiler le chiffre exact des
morts et des victimes
alors dans cette situation quand il y à
une décision étatique comme quoi il faut
pas être dévoilé le chiffre exact vous
pouvez imaginer à quel point on est dans
la confusion
on ne sait pas très bien ce qui se passe
et ce n'est pas d'ailleurs la première
fois que je précise que la république
islamique ne dévoile pas le chiffre des
victimes
on sait que après six mois on ne sait
pas encore combien de morts combien de
victimes on a eu au mois de novembre
alors que auront été dévoilé le chiffre
de 1500 personnes
l'état iranien refuse encore de dévoiler
le chiffre exact
la même stratégie pour le coronavirus
après plusieurs mois
on ne sait pas exactement ce qui se
passe dans ce pays on ne sait pas encore
combien de victimes
les seules informations que nous avons
pu obtenir était de la part des médecins
qui ont retrouvé les statistiques des
différents hôpitaux
ce qu'on a connu ce qu on a pu
comprendre est extrêmement alarmants
dans le sens où on est en face d'un cas
médicalement atypique dans le sens où
les victimes pour la plupart sont très
très jeune
l'iran est le seul pays pour l'instant
où les morts de coronavirus ont 100 kg
en exhumant de 30 ans donc une
population entre 20 et 30 ans les
victimes de covile 19
donc c'est un cas atypique alors on sait
évidemment vous venez de le décrire la
situation et
est grave même si on n'en connaît pas
l'ampleur et l'importance on peut se
demander pourquoi l'iran est-il le pays
le plus touché du proche et du
moyen-orient aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on a
un début d'explication
écoutez c'est très simple parce que
c'est le pays en ce moment qui est sous
les sanctions c'est le pays où
l'économie est complètement paralysé
déjà depuis 40 ans la mauvaise gestion
du pays
on complète a complètement paralysé
l'économie
les dernières années l'économie
iranienne était moribonde à la cause des
sanctions cette économie est encore plus
malade et donc fonctionne plus c'est
tourner est en face d'une population
quasiment affamés la mauvaise nutrition
a fait baisser la défense immunitaire de
la population c'est pourquoi même les
jeunes de 30 ans ne parviennent pas
résister au virus
les stratégies mises en place par le
pouvoir central est particulièrement
critiquée elle aussi à tort à raison
selon vous écoutez bas de toute façon en
a qu'on critique jamais assez la
république islamique parce que il a
complètement laissé tomber la gestion de
pays
le pays est vraiment quand on écoute les
iraniens moi je ça fait quand même des
années que je fais mes enquêtes à
travers les réseaux sociaux du
systématisme en contact avec les jeunes
les iraniens disent en fait qu' on n'a
pas donc on a pas un gouvernement on n'a
pas les hommes politiques on n'a pas des
responsables politiques qui s'occupent
d'eux des problèmes intérieurs
c'est pourquoi quand il ya virus comme
corona qui arrivent dans le pays la
plupart d'entre eux sur les réseaux
sociaux on les entend qu'il dise que ma
finalement locaux vides est devenue la
complice du régime avant c'était le
régime lui-même qui nous tuait et la
maintenance est la maladie donc voilà et
ils sont dans une situation totalement
désespérée et ils ne savent pas du tout
sortis ils peuvent compter alors les
états unis on ne sait continuer à mettre
la pression sur l'iran quelle peut être
la position de la communauté
internationale pour venir en aide aux
pays qui
venez l'expliqué souffre économiquement
et maintenant sur cette question
importante de santé publique
et quelle que soit la situation de la
santé publique ce qui est catastrophique
en ce moment quelle que soit la
situation ce qui est évident qu'il ya
une grande partie je dirais pas tous les
iraniens une grande partie de la
population iranienne sont contre ce
régime ne veut plus de la république
islamique parce qu'après 41 ans
ce régime a montré son incapacité pour
gérer ce pays
il a mis en fait le pays à feu et à sang
ça fait plus de deux mois que les forêts
iraniennes sont en feu
ça fait un moment que les installations
iraniens sont prêts le feu les unes
après les autres
donc vraiment le pays est complètement
délabré alors dans cette situation la
seule solution que la plupart des
iraniens comme je peux entendre à
travers leurs commentaires à travers
leur souhait c'est que les européens
arrête soutenir la république islamique
et laisser ce régime partir et que les
iraniens finalement arrive à gérer leur
pays par eux mêmes et que ces mots là
ils ont montré qu'en même après 41 ans
qui sont incapables de gérer ce pays
alors basta fini arrêter de soutenir la
république islamique
s'il vous plaît merci beaucoup marnage
sheikh ali d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france